when he looks crazy but he always did
but it looks like you're tired crazy
right now and Joe Biden he looks like
he's just exhausted I don't know what
happened to him but he was adjusted and
he doesn't do any work he's not working
Quinnipiac poll out in Florida says that
Sanders Biden Warren moody judge right
now would beat you
I know but boot adage you do believe
that really do you believe it they also
had me losing Texas to Pocahontas I'm
not losing Texas to anybody it's so much
fun to read it in Spanish
[Music]
another week another wonderful learning
experience first the campaign kicked off
in Orlando that's in Florida where we
learned what would happen if Trump
deleted one email if I deleted one email
like a love note to Melania it's the
electric chair for Trump I know that
feeling he also learned some history
like does anyone have a higher
percentage than your favorite president
Donald Trump one person has a higher
percentage than your favorite president
Donald Trump do you know who that
president is he's got a higher
percentage than me and it's devastating
his name is George Washington George is
at 100% and
no way I'm gonna get there no matter
what I tell you man and what about the
wall is it moving along the wall is
moving along it's moving along rapidly
it's beautiful I change the design it's
stronger bigger a better and cheaper you
know sometimes when they don't give you
the money you have to make it cheaper
it's true but do we have to pay you pay
for the very distinct privilege of not
having to pay but you had to pay a lot
now you don't have to pay any more I
have no idea what that meant but I asked
do you need a magic wand you need a
magic wand to bring back manufacture
well will tell sleepy Joe that we found
the magic wand you know at least he has
a lot of brilliant talented campaign
people we have a lot of brilliant talent
campaign people they cost a fortune and
they never give me any ideas I'm only
kidding you know he's not kidding
it makes you wonder what country you're
in PACA mega mega country we're in
maggot country that I could tell you
that I can't tell you now as you know
Magga is no longer the motto it's now
Keep America great or tagged which
sounds like a finished death metal group
and it is a departure see the first
motto Magga said hey it's time for a
change the new one says let's preserve
what we've changed I can't wait to see
the slogan for his third term
anyway
but as he no that's impossible people
it's impossible but as he throws his
first political tailgate the Orlando
Sentinel a paper pulled the first to an
anti endorsement of Trump even before
the Dems have a nominee meaning they
hate Trump so much the Dems could
nominate a desiccated zombie raccoon and
they go with a desiccated zombie raccoon
but enough about Bernie Sanders I still
think it's a little infantile much like
CNN who after being insulted at the
rally actually shut their coverage down
proving how emotional they really are
I'm surprised they didn't shout I hate
all of you then run upstairs and slam
their door and fling themselves on the
bed sobbing into a clutched pillow but
but at least they provided coverage for
some creepy stuff the academic
definition of concentration camps
targeting a community
[Music]
putting them in detention camps without
doing is she right in defining
concentration camps yes but do they have
a feeling of usage staying with what
happened with the Nazis and the genocide
of the Jews yes oh so as one side
celebrates a country the other floats in
an impervious idiotic bubble insulting
Holocaust victims and then justifying
with some lame semantics again the
contrast this is Trump and this is her
as critics
you can do it over now I'm bad at
predicting things but I know this the
side that's having the most fun usually
wins on the Republican side it's fun on
the Democrats it's a funk a deep dark
smelly bottom of the laundry hamper funk
you know where the socks have already
gone stiff every candidate staking out
the gloomiest vision for a country so
thank thank heavens Trump will be live
tweeting the debates how awesome is that
people people won't be watching the
debates they'll be watching him watching
the debates the Democrats should be
thrilled over this fact is if there's
one person who can make a meek luma char
or interacts well well interesting it's
not Amy Klobuchar or Eric sois well it's
Trump and his tweet machine but it's
hard to see how special it really is
when you're in it it's one of those
times that could only be revealed when
you're looking back at it decades from
now lucky for you I took my time machine
to the future and found the perfect
product hi I'm Tom Shalu you know me as
the guy whose face makes you feel safe
but you forget in just a few minutes
well I'm thrilled to share with you a
collection like no other I won't talk
about Jeb Bush I will not say I will not
say he's low-energy I will not say
I will not say it now for the first time
ever all the unforgettable Trump hits
are together in one must app collection
star unicorn Entertainment and Greg Life
present the best of Trump
before we go any further I'd like to
introduce my co-host cat Tim hello you
might recognize me from such films as
Titanic 17 Jack's Revenge but today I'm
excited to look back on the voice that
defined an era
Donald supported the invasion of Iraq
wrong that is absolute wrong over and
over again we actually the best of Trump
is great for when you want to have
friends over or if like me you have no
friends but want to relive the old days
of the campaign I am officially running
for president of the United States and
we are going to make our country great
again this collection brings back so
many great memories like before my wife
left me for her Aldo that's right Tom
and with more than 47,000 hours of
content you'll be transported back to
all the most iconic moments I'm cold
I think we should let me run the country
you run CNN or and if you did it well
your ratings let me ask you before if he
wanted this much Trump you'd have to
watch the news 24/7 and ignore your
family completely don't I know it cat my
son still won't talk to me but now I can
get the greatest Trump moments all in
one place whenever I want I can see
classics like get him out of here all
right get him out of here please get him
out
out go home to mommy how was your nap
cap it was great Tom you know it seems
like every clip in this set tells a
great story that's right
who could forget Bing Bing bong bong
Bing Bing Bing Bing Bing bong bong Bing
Bing Bing Joe that is you will find this
collection on CNN you're telling me
do you remember where's Nick Nick where
are you Nick stand down so order Trump
hits today call anytime within the next
four years and you'll receive a limited
edition lock of the president's hair in
a tiny glass bottle for no additional
charge
Trump it's rated M for mark former US
Marines bomb technician Staff Sergeant
Joey Joe
these need more job just drop than a
sexy orthodontist his comedy special I
got the house is now streaming
everywhere jim Florentine wait with the
clip her glasses are thick but they're
part of her stick host of sincerely
Catherine Fox they should get did
he's a shoplifter meaning he can
actually lift an entire shop my massive
sidekick and host of nuff said on Fox
Nation Tyrus
[Applause]
so Joe we what are you making a campaign
kickoff well I love the video by the way
and then the second little cat jumping
and that's me getting on an escalator
[Laughter]
everybody's legs he's cool with it be
cool with it with him I'm a bit of a
one-trick pony over here listen if I
ever reads
arguing with Holocaust survivors over
the definition of concentration camps if
ever reached that level of my political
career I had put you know put a fork in
me I'm done yeah that level of stupidity
doesn't have any place in American
politics which leads me to believe the
the conspiracy theory that she's an
actress that's been hired by the
Democratic Party yes so I stop there
yeah okay gonna get mad Jim what is she
making the week so far I thought he was
great I mean a lot he got a lot of
criticism because he was complaining in
the first hour yeah but you know he has
every right to complain
they've been on him Democrats won't work
with them you know the mullah report was
hanging over his head all the time the
media's against them the media is almost
like a nagging wife they just pick at
them they look at any little thing look
at the way he on that can you believe it
you know so man you just got divorced
[Laughter]
that's why my comedy specials I got the
house yes did you get the house yeah you
got the house yeah is it a nice house oh
yeah well congratulations oh yeah just
call me PD prenup anyway so it was good
you know just did he got anything done
in the first two and a half years he's
amazing with all that I mean the guys
are an animal
I kind of want you to do the movie that
you said you were in which is Titanic
14-7 Jack's revenge and I'm excited for
that in your future I've been writing it
yes and you you make it ech you make an
excellent elderly cat Tim thank you so I
want to go back to to what you were
talking about about aoc and her
concentration camps thing that was so
stupid I was trying to think of what it
was like so I wrote a bunch of analogies
but I couldn't decide which one I liked
best okay so I'm just gonna say them all
okay okay okay
that's like saying having a cold is like
having cancer mm-hmm
that's like saying your phone dying is
like your mom dying that's like saying
that wearing a tie that's too tight is
like being beheaded that's like saying
that eating hot soup mm-hmm and having
it burn your mouth is like being burned
alive while eating hot soup interesting
and that's like saying breaking a
fingernail is as bad as having a nail in
your finger
it's hard to pick from those which I
didn't know which one to pick so they
all they all made the air yes
Tyrus I think I think that's accurate
because there were no one sentence to
describe the moronic nough said right
those of you left is like that's the
same thing as saying somebody breaks
into your house trips and falls and
breaks their neck and you go to jail for
murder yeah because that's kind of the
same thing Trump had a big week you know
he kicked it off and we didn't see the
Democrats again like it was once he got
on the news the only thing we had going
on was they're really mad at Joe Biden
for telling her how it is Cory Booker
was mad at Joe because Joe told the
truth of something actually happened in
a historic event not something that you
made up on Twitter or you know Cory
Booker is hilarious to me and as one
brother to another
I'm all for civil rights and fighting
for you know our stuff but his claim to
fame to go after Joe Biden is he wanted
to he led to legislation to let
everybody know that lynch mob is a crime
it's officially a crime yeah like we
didn't already know that if you form a
lynch mob you're going to jail yes